so I'm gonna explain what I'm doing and
I want you to watch carefully what's
happening in front of me okay so um I
have nothing up my sleeves all that kind
of thing
just just in case you're suspicious so I
have let's let's do it this way so you
can see it I have here am I can't even
do this probably but I have a standard
deck of cards here okay bye like he tell
me anytime if like something happens I
bump it you can't see just tell me come
not gonna keep looking okay yeah it's
because I need a light so you can see it
clearly it's alright it'll be fine so I
just a deck of cards here
okay now I'm actually really really you
know how there's that um you split the
deck and you do the shuffle thing so I'm
really uncoordinated so I can't do that
okay so I need some can someone do that
can anyone you do it so now I'm going to
do something let me explain it and then
I'll do it okay I'm about to make four
piles of cards on my desk and I'm gonna
do it in a very particular way okay I'm
going to take out a card I'm gonna look
at it and I said okay what color is that
okay so this is red so this is my red
pile now okay this is my red pile once I
put one card down I'm going to put an
unknown one beside it so these are my
first two piles okay then I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna alternate every time I'm
gonna look at a card not look at a car
look at a card not look at a car okay so
my next card is red so it goes here
so my next unknown goes in the same one
my next one's black so that comes with
its unknown over there so here are my
four piles and now all I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna alternate okay so I'm gonna
look at the card red so the unknown goes
there it's gonna be a bit messy but stay
with me
red unknown black unknown okay you get
the idea so yeah sorry I'm doing the
whole deck okay it's a standard deck
without Jokers okay
understood
so it's it has a specific purpose I
guess okay okay so now I've got let me
tidy it up a teeny little bee here now
I've got a red pile and a black pile and
I'm gonna call this one the secret red
pile and the secret black pot okay yeah
I know right
so it's so you can keep track right now
I had to die here somewhere where did it
go it's disappeared
someone see my die it doesn't matter I
don't need to is it that there is this
guy okay so I want you to look at this
for a second now have a look at my
unknown piles those are the most
important ones here okay those unknown
piles are very unknown I don't know much
about them I don't know the cars that
are in them in fact if you were paying
attention you'd notice even though
they're kinda like roughly the same size
I have no idea how many cards are in
either of those piles okay so I don't
know very much about these pauses what
I'm trying to say now I'm gonna make me
make me know even less about the piles
I'm gonna take some of the cards from
this pile the unknown black and put them
swap them with the cards in the unknown
red okay so to work out how many cards I
should do I'm just gonna go six okay yep
so I'm gonna go let's see one two three
just for to be interesting let's take
three from the bottom one two three
okay so these six they came from the
unknown black pile okay I'm going to
swap in with one two three let's be
that's three right let's be weed and
take them for like the middle or
something one two three okay so I've got
six cards from the unknown red and I've
got six cards from the unknown black so
I'm going to swap them now so this one
goes over here this one goes over here
are you following me so far okay so here
we go here comes the let's hope this
works I'm gonna make a prediction okay I
predict I predict that this the unknown
red pile right I predict that the number
of red cards in this pile
this is the unknown black pile is the
same as the number of black cards in
this pile the reading here and the
number of blacks in here okay
now I don't even know the sizes of these
PI's well how many reds or blacks there
are so I'm gonna need you to help me
count okay I'm gonna put them down and
because I'm looking at the unknown Reds
right now I just want you to help me
count the Reds can you do it out loud
okay so I'm looking for Reds
looking for Reds okay okay so you got
the number for red cards okay for a cut
all right huh that'll be embarrassing is
what will happen okay all right so I've
got my four red cards here I'm just
gonna put these all to one sax I don't
need them anymore so I'm predicting
there should be four black cards in here
that's my prediction
okay so you ready let's put these guys
off to the side help me count no no
black eyes black cards okay
so for Red's for blacks what the random
okay now let's just think about this
right think about this so yeah the
tremendous advantage of knowing you in a
maths class right now this is not magic
it's not even sleight of hands okay it's
nice it's mathematics okay now here's
what I want you to get right we've been
looking at like triangles and stuff like
that when you understand patterns and
relationships you can predict things you
can know things that people like how did
you work that out exactly because I
understand the mathematics the patterns
are relationships that are underneath
what's going on it's a whole lot of math
going on under here this kind of
disguised from you you don't know it I
do and that's why I need the treatment
what okay so now I want you to see like
what was I doing I was taking advantage
of a pattern a relationship that I knew
about that you didn't know okay well now
if we come back to these guys right okay
wake up you know about all these secret
patterns and relationships that are
going on underneath what people know we
can see the three patterns and
relationships we're thinking about are
called sine cos and tan they are a
hidden fact that you now understand how
they work so you can use them to predict
you should be able to nerve
but you can